rural Eastern Cape is one of the poorest
and least developed provinces in South
Africa Children Here attend zamukanyo
Farm school they take their lessons in
pre-fabricated classrooms until the
government builds permanent structures
one of the many challenges here is
overcrowding it's not easy to teach them
when they are so overcrowded in the
classrooms
it's totally difficult totally difficult
because when you go to other classes
they they their table is there just in
front of the of the chalkboard so there
are so many
there are so many kids it's not easy the
children live in neighborhoods where
there is high unemployment and poverty
activists say education in the Eastern
Cape is in crisis because of government
corruption and mismanagement parents
concerned about the quality of schooling
their children are receiving often can't
afford to move them to better equipped
schools
new permanent schools such as this one
are being built by the state officials
say education in South Africa still
suffers from the legacy of Decades of
apartheid where black children were
given inferior education and resources
if you go back to the Nelson Mandela Bay
where I'm coming from you will see these
dilapidated wooden schools that are
falling apart we are taking them one by
one in fixing these schools to give our
people better infrastructure yes at
times people feel that we're too slow in
our movement but it's not the case it is
just the challenges we're facing are so
enormous this school was recently built
but like several other state-run schools
in the province challenges such as
overcrowding persist teachers and
students at zamukanya Farm School are
still waiting for their school to be
built until that happens teachers say
they are doing the best they can with
the little they've got
South Africa
no Hong Kong has held its
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera